咱们又上课了啊。
好几天没更新了，没上课。
为啥呢？
工作了呀。
哈哈。
咱这个课开始录的时候，是因为疫情嘛。
隔离停产停工也没事干。
所以当时说录一套完整的编剧课。
提供给大家呢学习和交流。
也其实也是给我自己一个梳理。
但是现在已经开始工作了。
只能抽空录。
但咱绝对不会撂下。
有始有终对大家负责任。
这个课呢我说我们开始的很荒诞，但绝对不能结束的很潦草。
误打误撞的爱情也得给他整到天荒地老，行不行？
咱们呢之前我看了一下。
讲了8个部分的内容。
十六节课被不老少了。
我也不知道你们学的啥样。
上网课就这点不好。
学生不在身边。
你也没办法知道大家的学习进度。
哪里有疑问，哪里需要再回归炉再重点讲一讲。
所以这只能靠大家自觉了。
有不懂的地方，要不就。
再回看一下。
或者呢其实可以发私信给我。
趁咱现在粉丝也不多。
我能我能handle的过来。
你们可以在这个B站。
或者抖音上给我发发私信。
微博也行。
呃，最方便的其实是那个加我们的公众号。
也叫查理的编剧课。
可以加那个学习交流的微信群，那里提问啊。
呃，答疑解惑呀会更方便一点。
还有同学建议我做做做一次直播。
直播我确实不太会，但我研究研究吧，我感觉直播可能也。
也挺适合大家交流。
琢磨琢磨好吧。
在这之前呢，咱还是按照咱们的教学计划往下讲。
前面8个部分的内容。
咱们其实通篇讲了故事的要素呀。
还有这个呃四目视。
十个序列的故事群。
从这节课开始呢。
我把其中的重点部分。
着重的展开的。
来给大家讲一讲。
今天这节课。
咱们讲人物。
讲人物啊人物那显然是很重要呀。你给别人讲一个故事，肯定是先说我这个故事。
关于谁谁谁的。
就谁谁谁就是咱们的人物。
人物非常重要。
呃，人物是什么呢？
人物其实就是你。
对自己的自知。
你们说过吗？西诃夫说过，不是我说过说你对人性的认知都来源于你自己，不管是最卑劣的还是最圣洁的，都来源于你自己。
所以你创造的人物呢实际上也是你对自己的一次。
自我探索。
自我探究是你的自知。
所以我们必须。
爱我们的人物。
爱我们创造的每一个人物。
你都不爱。
那，你能让观众爱吗？
讲人物咱们还是老规矩。
先从最主要的。
主角。
咱们先讲主角。
前面我们在讲课的时候，我经常说咱们这个角色他需要有什么样的身份，什么样的动作，什么样的欲望，然后遇到什么样的事儿，面临什么样的环境，采取什么样的行动，随后又面临什么样的挣扎，取得什么样的结果？
咱们一直说的。
就是主。
因为主角最重要主角最关键。
啥叫主角？
定义上说，主角就是推动故事发展的。
那个人。
这叫主角。
既然要推动故事发展，咱们可以这么理解。
主角呢？
就是拥有主动力。
行拥有行动力。
但那是。
就是有力的那个人。
办事儿的那个人。
往前推着走，牵着走的那个人。
那个人是主角。
这是主角的定义。
在没学这个编剧之前啊，很多人对主角的理解往往是主角嘛？这不是那个戏份最多的那个人。
是吧或者最出彩的那个人。
是吧最大腕的那个人最帅的那个人。
往往是这么理解啊，这不对。
主角是需有行动力和主动力的人那个。
当然啊大部分时候主角是。
气氛最多的。
也是最出彩。
也通常也是最大腕的那个或者是最帅的那个是吧？大部分时候是那样，但绝对不是那么去区分的。
所，大家举个例子，大家就知道了。咱们之前说过那个呃举例子说二次行为的时候。
我给大家说过那个哆啦A梦。
大雄跟哆啦A梦。
你说这个戏谁是主角？
大雄跟哆啦A嘛，他俩谁是主？
有些人会说是哆啦A梦为啥？
这个戏就叫哆啦A梦呀。
那主角当然是哆啦A梦了。
而且哆啦A梦多出彩啊是吧？有各种道具。
还是个机器猫。
这个不对。
这个就是一个典型的例子，哆啦A梦的主角是大雄。
大熊是拥有主动力和行动力的那个人。
每次都是他惹事儿，或者是他有什么诉求，对吧？今天想去。
跟胖怕虎呃闹别扭了，明天想去报复一下强夫，后天又干哎呀，景象实在太美好了。
他老有欲望，有动作。
有行动。
然后呢去去争取一次争取，二次争取。
激情吗哆啦A梦是是配合他的。
帮助他的。
所以说主角毫毫无争议的就是大雄。
这是一个比较典型的例子。
这是主角的定义。
咱们因为是网课啊，我也不考试。
不需要你去背定义，你只需要去给我理解。
理解了才是你的。有时候背下来一个定义，一个字不差，能默写出来没有用。好吧，主角就是推动故事前进的那个人。
有主动力，有行动力的能力。
还有同学会有疑问啊，说那有些戏我看的主角挺被动。
比如说灾难片。
呃，这个地球毁灭呃，山洪爆发对吧？
那你作为一个角色，你太渺小了。
你主动什么呀？你主动你很被动啊。
还有什么侏罗纪公园，那恐龙都跑出来了，要吃人，所有人都在逃命。那你主动什么，你全是被动的逃命。
这个主动被动不是这么理解的。
山洪爆发也好。
这个西公园那恐龙活了也好。
这都是激励事件。
你可以在吉利事件以前这个主角。
啊，是被动的。但是你只要一激励完他，他马上变主动，你去看。
侏罗纪公园里，那恐龙到处咬人。
所有人都逃命，没错，但是是谁带着大家逃？
是谁想办法让大家逃，是谁想出主意逃，谁保护大家那个主动的人。
有主动力的那就是主角。
那就是主角。
所以说这是主角的一个定义。
好吧，我们再来看一下主角的作用。
主角的作用。
定义啊。
主角的作用啊。
之前好像也说过。
我说啥是主角？
主角就是带着你看故事的那个人。
就带着你经历这个故事的人，你讲了一个故事啊，你想让观众看呀，谁带着观众看？
主角带着观众看。
主角是观众的眼睛，是观众的导导游。
或者是观众跟主角灵魂附体，就体会他的这个这个惊恐、希望冲动。
恐惧难过，就是跟着他走，他是带着观众。
看故事的那个人。
明白吗？
我们称之为。
视角。
然后他凭什么能带呢？
他是靠什么？
能带着观众带着。
带观众。
经历我们的故事呢，他凭什么能带观众经历我们的故事，他靠什么呢？
反复说。
靠的是共情。
对不对？靠的是共情呀。
哎，我们说啥叫共情？共情也有定义啊。
共情是人类共同的情感。
就是你有共同的情感，他才能感同身受，明白吗？
观众必须跟你共情，跟你的主角共情情。
希望他。
就观众希望他赢。
这么简单理解，这个好好理解吗？
观众希望他赢，那这个人就是主角。
或者是理解为他想办的事儿。
得到了观众的理解和认可，你也可以这么理解呃，共情这个事儿。
我说说说挺简单的啊，啊感觉好像也就是那这个基本的道理啊。
我跟你说，很多出写者就是不懂。
就是不懂。
写出来的东西啊。
我就说咱们班啊，咱班的有个同学我就不点名了，交上来的作业。
他写了一个。
一个很叛逆的少年。然后呢，比如说。
离家出走，离经叛道，然后倍有个性，觉得哎呀，我那都都都都世界跟我八字不合。
然后呢觉得自己特酷，特有个性，流浪街头浪迹天涯。
就是人物设定中的杀马特。
但年轻人往往觉得这种角色挺酷的，而且总觉得这种从这种角色里面能找到自己的影子，所以特别爱写。
他就失去了一个共情呀。
他就失去了共情了呀。
不是人类共同的情感。
你想离家出走不要紧。
你给我个理由啊。
你先取得观众的理解和支持呀。
你觉得你父母。
不想要跟你父母决裂，你给我个礼。
就是这样。
你得有共情。
他们虐待你啊，那可以，那你先这交代他们虐待你。
就是这个问题，很多同学就特别不注意这个啊。
共情非常重要。
我所以我们在主角这里啊，我想展开给大家讲讲呢，就是这个共情的。
如何制造共情和加强共情？
好不好？我们来研究一下这个问题。
共情是人类共同的情感。
如何让？
观众。
和你的主角建立共情。
那我们就来分析一下啊。
我们回到八要素。
大家回顾一下。
我们说人物的。
人物的三个要素。
是啥来着？
身份。
欲望。
动作。
当时分这个的时候啊，很多人还会。
心里和昏末碎碎念啊，觉得哎身份跟人物有关，欲望跟动作啊，为什么归在人物这个？
因为我们弄的归在事件那儿。
我跟你说这么分，他就是有道理的。
人物。
分成这三个部分。
你现在要。
使你的人物。
更加具有共情。
就是从这三个方面入手。
我们逐个来说。
身份。
如何让你的人物的身份？
更具有共情。
我们说有三个方法。
三个方法有个口诀。
叫可怜。
可信。
从身份上下手啊。
让你的人物更具备共情。
就是这三个口诀，可怜可惜可爱。
可怜啥意思？
可怜比较适用于小人物小人物出场。
小人物。
被人欺负。
郁郁不得志，挣不着钱。
失去父母的爱，失去亲人。
或者是环境极其险恶。
这些描述。
都。
可以让你的主角可怜起来。
可怜。
就会很好的很快的。
很廉价的获得。
观众的共情。
很多周星驰的片子，金凯丽的片子、喜剧片。
耍来就。
从这里下手。
很简单很有效，好吧，这是一种方法。
就让他可怜。
这不俗啊，你可以自己想办法处理这个不俗。
我给你举个例子吧，大家说那可怜这个会不会太俗啊，上来泡妞泡不着啊，或者是走在路上被人揍一顿。
来去年那个小丑。
呃，你们这这个这个大家影视爱好者都都把小丑共成祖宗，都在那特别爱看。
小丑上来那个小丑莫名其妙被人打一顿，你记不记得？
小丑在路边。
这个这个做他的工作呃，在那儿宣传拿广告牌嘛，人肉广告牌在那宣传，然后被人把广告牌抢走，引到一个巷子里，莫名其妙暴打一顿。
那群人也不知道也不是为了什么。
对吧就是想揍他。
跟他也没有仇，也不是想抢钱，就是要揍他。
这可怜呀，这并不俗。
大师也也在用对吧？但是我见过用的比较好玩的，我给大家讲一个那个快速的讲一个啊，那个有一个电影叫泰迪熊，是个二级片。
虽然动画片但是个二级片里面讲那个。
呃，男主角。
男主角就是泰极熊的朋友，注意啊，主角不是泰极熊。
他结婚的那个朋友，那哥们儿。
他小时候。
可怜出场，就是没有人愿意跟他玩。
他就说他小时候没有愿意没有人跟他玩儿，然后开场。
然后呢，第一个场景就是一帮小孩在揍，一帮小孩在欺负一个小孩。另外一个小孩，那被欺负的小孩在地上被人暴揍。
你理所当然的认为他想塑造这个男主角可怜，挨揍的就是他。但是旁白想起说我们的每一个社区。
都有这么一群欺负人的孩子。
和一个瘦小的。
呃，不受不招人待见的犹太小孩，因为小时候人家有种族隔阂嘛，犹太小孩被几个什么wap安格鲁萨克逊的那种小白人小孩在那揍。
然后。
这时候另外一个小孩走过来。
说我可不可以跟你们一块玩儿？
然后打人的那帮小孩叫他滚开。
被揍的那个小孩也叫他滚开，啥意思啊？就是连挨揍的挨揍的那个犹太小孩都瞧不起他。然后这时候镜头跟着这个小孩走，他才是我们的主角。
就他的可怜啊并不是挨揍，是挨揍都捞不着。
这个就是这是题外话啊，就给大家举个例子，可怜啊并不low。
是可以做好的对吧？我们想想大师也都在做，周星驰也在用，小丑也在用，你有什么？
你有什么不好意思用的呢？
可怜。
一招啊塑造一个险恶的环境啊，或者从。
最切肤之痛的那些事儿失去。
呃，这个亲人啊对吧？没有钱。
都是很容易让观众觉得。
观众为什么可怜？
因为他也没钱。
是吧你说没有钱，他也没钱，他就马上给你站在一一伙了。我说共情嘛？不就是让观众给你站一块儿吗？
可惜。
可惜是怎么怎么回事呢？
就是我们创造角色的时候啊。
要让这个角色。
让观众信。
让观众信服，并不是说你一定要写一个观众见过的人。
而是写一个让观众觉得合理的人。
比如说黑社会大哥，谁见过黑社会大哥呀？
对吧咱社会主义国家哪有黑社会呀，因没见过呀。
但是你得让他信福呀。
让他幸福，就是这样创造一个让。
让观众信服的角色。
一般来说啊，咱们写角色的出发点都是想让这个角色。
更特别。
更容易让人记住。
或者更。
啊让观众啊一下觉得啊这么一个角色，你更关注的是那个点。
更关注角色special。
unique。
往往就忽略了可信。所以在可信这儿我教大家一个方法。
就是给你塑造的那个不得了的角色。
设计一个缺陷。
或者叫什么呢？
就坏习惯也可以。
我比较喜欢用坏习惯。
设计一个缺陷或者坏习惯。
比如说。
一个壮壮汉，或者是一个很看起来很威武的角色。
特别馋。
啊，特别爱吃糖吧，爱吃甜食。
呃，一个大佬。
闲着没事就要吃彩虹糖。
还不能给小弟们看到，有点丢脸呀，还自己偷偷跑去买。
被小弟撞过，还要说，哎，我不是来买对吧？别的就是这么一。
爱吃巧克力。
赌神高进。
周润发那个不吃巧地，他就连赌博都不会。
是际种。
小缺陷，小坏习惯。
或者是一个。
呃，这个这个。
呃，一个大男人很怕蟑螂，很怕老鼠。
这都是经常用的。
就是可以让你的角色更可信。为啥？因为你观众会觉得啊他也怕老鼠，他也怕蟑螂。
又拉近距离了。
我过去可信这一块，就设计缺陷这块，很多人喜欢用酗酒。
或者是不修边幅，这个就用的太多了。
慢慢的就这个这个这个。
共情就差了。所以可信这里设计缺陷，设计坏习惯，好吧，这也是一个很好的招。
可爱哎，这个就就比较关键了。
可爱不是说卡哇伊啊。
可爱的意思是可以去爱。
值得爱。
的意思值得爱。
可爱。
一般啊。
用一个啥方法啊，让他可爱呢？
去做一件小美好。
做一件小善事儿。
有一本书专门讲这个的。
叫救猫咪。
叫救猫咪呀。
我觉得有些同学肯定看过。
救猫咪是个是啥书啊？
救猫咪是一套书。
是美国好莱坞一个很著名的这个这个编剧教学工作者。
斯戴德先生，他搞的这一套教学，很多拥趸，在好莱坞啊有很多拥趸，德国奥斯卡的都有在国内，你像。
呃，宁浩导演。
呃，徐峥老师都是走。
他这个流派的。
他这个流派我简单说一下啊，后面会讲到就是。
他喜欢讲类型片，他把所有的电影分成10个类型，然后每个类型呢总结出一些诀窍。
一些很简单的诀窍。
我不建议大家现在去看，因为那个东西太。
太归纳总结了，你现在还没有基础。
就去看那个。
容易被带歪了。
我后面会给大家着重讲一讲。
他的那种思维和方式。
现在我们先就说他的这个理论就是救猫咪理论。
他认为呢你的主角出场以后必须要救一只小猫。
当然了，这是比喻。
就一只小狗也是可以的，对吧？
或者你正好在海边救一个小海龟，我觉得也可以。
就一个小朋友，很可爱的小朋友也可以啥意思呢？就是做一件美好的小善事。
做一件美好的小善事。
你自己去回忆，有好多好多片子，你自己去看啊。
凡是所有的强男。
强南医啊。
开场的电影只要是好莱坞的。
或者是这几年的商业片啊。
都有九毛。
有候就真的就救个猫。
就这么字面。
呃，的去办都有去年那个办个喜剧。
呃，我们单位的麻花的那个半个喜剧那个电影。
男一上来第一场戏完事之后，下楼就去喂流浪猫。
救妈咪。
好吧。
这种啊呃在这个斯奈德的体系里面，他认为是必须的。
我认为呢一般适合于强人。
强忍。
你想这个身份如果很可怜啊。
其实是没有必要。
据说你看周星驰的片子，他如果上来非常可怜。
其实它是没有必要救猫咪的。
你只要不停的在。
环境非常险恶，被欺负，被辱骂，你还能保持初心，保持善良就足够了，不用再去救一只流浪猫了。
因为他可怜出场，你觉得周星驰不懂商业片吗？他当然懂啊，他知道救猫咪，我给你举个简单的例子。
你就知道周星驰他懂不懂了。
周星驰难得演强人出场的片子吧。
难得眼吧。
对不对？
偶尔演的几次是什么？
苏乞儿。
苏琪儿是强人开场。
哎呀，武功也无敌，钱也无敌，上来25岁大寿逛窑子，对吧？但是到了窑子以后，马上打赏乞丐也是人。
给他钱，让他逛。
让他嫖让他吃。
救猫咪乞丐。
在这里就是猫。
懂吗？
周星驰也懂他会玩这一套。
强人开场的时候，他他也会玩，但是他大部分时候不需要，是因为他他弱小开场。
所以你看啊。
人物的身份这个层面。
要加强共情。
三张可怜可信。
可爱可爱是指可以去爱。
让你的这个人物做一件小美好。
小善良。
让观众给观众一个爱他的理由。
身份层面加强。
我们说从欲望层面。
啊，可不可以加强供给？
当然可以，而且我教过大家。
教过大家关于欲望，我说过什么？
欲望讲给猴子听。
欲望讲给猴子听呀。
那有只猴子，你去跟他说，哎，那有个母猴，他马上跟你走，对不对？记不记得？
原始。
比如说原始的欲望。
更能激起。
人类的共情，我们说共情共情的定义是什么？人类共同的情感。
我让你讲给猴子听是更强一层，这是他妈是灵长类共同的情感，这就不是人类的问题了。
所以原始的欲望。
越原始欲望，越能激起人类的共情。
我说的夸张点，你如果越欲望足够原始，你其他什么角色情节都不写，就单一个欲望这个片子都。
有是大家都从头看到尾。
有的片子就是给你看一个原始的欲望，它没有情节，没有人物关系，没有主角配角，就单单让你看欲望，你不也看的挺美的吗？还去网上找去下载。
对吧就是给你开一个原始欲望。
是不是？
当然了，我肯定不是说黄片。
是吧。
我说的是比如说。
荒野求生类的片子。
就你就看把人困在小岛，他如何求生，这就是一个原始欲望，它其他什么也没有，就给你看一个原始的求生欲望。
你就从头看到尾。
还有人喜欢看吃播，看别人吃东西。
就是看一个原始欲望呀。
他没有情节，没有故事呀，他就在那不停的吃，你就在那不停的看。
那你说电影有没有？
那个。
Md max。
疯狂的麦克斯。
从头到尾讲一个男的逃命。
男主角。
逃命。
后面有追兵，他不停的在逃，一路上披荆斩棘，受尽折磨，就是要逃命，就是要活命。
没有什么情节。
就是靠原始欲望一根一股仙气儿支撑你看俩多钟头，而且md max都非常好看，我很爱干视觉盛宴呀。
所以说你愿欲欲望足够原始，都能给你把片子撑下来，就是一个原始欲望，啥也没有。
您不也看的挺美吗？
来，所以。
在欲望上增强共情。
方法就是原始。
在动作呢。
动作如何？
产生共情。
动作产生共情的方法。
就是。
得到观众的许可。
就是你的这个。
你的这个主角，他做的每一件事情。
你现在要去做一件事情。
要做之前你都去给我想一想，我去做这件事情。
我后面那一排排的观众给了我许可了吗？
给你许可了吗？
前面有个姑娘很漂亮。
我想去得到它，这是一个原始的欲望。你的观众。
没有问题的，他跟你产生共情，看到漂亮姑娘，谁不想。
然后你的动作是什么？
拿迷药上去迷间。
马上你的观众不可以不可以。
对吧你先先获得他们的许可。
你的动作假设真的是民间，那你必须先铺垫这个姑娘。
你追求过。
他不同意。
然后呢，他还羞辱你。
而且不是一般的羞辱你。
羞辱到什么程度这羞就指着鼻子骂你爹妈。
然后这时候你回头看看关众。
观众也想想，这女的确实他妈也不是东西。
然后你手里正好又有一个迷药，你又给观众看一看，你看这不是我提前准备的，这是家里翻出来的。你看看你看看，然后观众看看迷药，看看那个臭娘们儿。
上你这时候才获得到观众的许可。
明白这个意思吗？
特别是在做坏事的时候嘛。
你说你这个主角是一个杀手，上来要杀人。
我们说这个杀手不太冷。
让雷洛上来要杀人。
你也得获得观众的许可呀。
你也得告诉观众，你看我是不得已的，我是被程序人养大了，我是个孤儿，我除了杀人，什么也不会干。
他们从小培养我杀人，我不知道是非对错。
他们现在又让我去杀一个人，而且我跟他们反复商量说，我再杀呃两个可不可以让我退休？
然后观众说，那你杀了杀了杀，赶紧杀够数啊，观众认可徐克你了。
就是这个问题，对吧？你看到一个银行。
这个你想去抢银行，必须先获得观众的许可。
对吧因为你想要钱，观众是认可的，这个欲望是没问题的。
你说我想去抢那个银行。
然后观众马上拦着你啊，说你太太。
你打工去呀，你对吧？劳动致富，你打工去啊，然后你俩手一大步啊。
打工是不可能打工的，这辈子都不可能打工的。
观众马上手一松就走了，他不看你这个故事了，他跟你断绝共情了。
因为你不讲理，你知道吗？你必须告诉观众，我试着打工了。
但是因为我是刑满释放人员。
没有地方要我，所有的人都歧视我。
对吧然后呢，那个特别是那个银行的人。
也歧视我。
不让我去存取钱，因为我在监狱里关了20年，我又没有微信支付，我又不懂网络银行。
但是我去取钱，他们提视我，而且他们不光提示我。刚才有一个捡破烂的老奶奶想进去取200块钱买菜，他们也把那个老奶奶轰出来了。
我还是我给那个老奶奶买了瓶矿泉水呢。
让观众想想，这银行确实也挺可恨啊。
而且你还救了一个老奶奶，哎，还救猫咪啊，你这人还行。
然后呢。
就一进行了一定的呃铺垫许可了吧。然后这时候。
你又有几个同伴跟你一起蹲过监狱的狱友。
全都吃不上饭，又来找你了。
他们也都找不到工作呀，被社会歧视呀，又来找你。然后呢，其中一个特别会开锁。
其中一个特别会钻动。
其中一个呢在银行当过保安。
啊。
安排你的关注哎。
啊，然后就关注。
看看这个情况，看看你想想你的欲望，考虑到你之前救过猫咪，再看看那个可恨的银行。
拍大腿瞧得到了观众的认可。
得到了观众的许可了。
对吧。
所以说你的动作。
你要得到观众的许可。
这就是把人物拆成三个部分之后，如何全方位的。
获得共情。
如何全方位的获得共给？
一定要记住共情不能断，你不能小马拉车啊，拉着拉着说哎，咱们抢银行。哎，咱们去前面有个妞，哎，哎，咱们去报仇哎，哪去了？
对吧你不能就给人撂下了，你一定要记住你是带着观众去。
主角嘛，你是主角主角要有这个责任，带着观众经历整个故事，不能把他们撂下，任在到结束也不能把他们撂下，始终在始终在始终在你车上。
就是说共情是我们主角这边最重要的。
当然我们说有没有例外？
有没有例外？
就说这些都没太做好，但是呢观众。
死心塌地的没下车，一直跟着你看这个故事，有有例外。
啥例外？
明星效应呀，要我说明星为啥值钱呢？拍一个戏好几千万呢？明星效应呀，我跟你说，明星啊很多时候不是有票房效应。
你看啊有些明星虽然很有名，但他其实没有票房效应，有这样的明星的。
有这样的明星呢？就虽然很有名脸熟，大家都见过这张脸，但他其实没有票房效应，但它有个什么作用啊？它有个共情效应。
他一演一个什么角色，你就知道哦，这个角色是主角哦他要去。
对吧办点什么事儿，你天然就跟他站在一块儿。
我说彭于演一出来。
彭于晏这个角色一出场。
完全没有。
交代过身份。
没有交代过欲望，也没有救过猫上来就哎。
前面有个大肚婆。
风裕有可呢，我就靠这一口，我要强奸他，对吧？
侯医院是多帅呀。
对吧又什么优质偶像，明星啊，所有的观众就一拍大腿上。
你贴着墙走贴着墙走，别让人看见那有摄像头高低点。
马上跟彭晏战成一伙呢，你知道吧？
不管他干的这个事儿有多丧尽天良。
不问的。
黄渤一出场。
对吧黄渤说啊，那个银行我要抢关众不问。
第一个镜头就是黄渤站在银行门口，准备要抢观众马上马上就支持我波哥，你子弹带够了吗？对吧？多带点啊，那保安会不少？
这这就是明星效应，那是例外情况，这个不在咱考虑之列啊，但是你看到这种戏，你别奇怪，明星对吧？
但咱们写故事不能考虑有明星，我们这奔着没有去。
啊吧，这是一种例外情况。
所以说共情啊是这么主角这里我给大家着重讲。
手重奖。
再给大家讲讲啊，再给大家讲一个就是说共情的极限是什么？
共情的极限啊。
极限操作啊有一种片子叫英雄片。
一种片子叫英雄片。
英雄片啊。
是很古老的一个片种。
讲一个超人的故事，讲一个什么。
大力神的故事，对吧？讲一个什这个孙悟空的故事。
这种属于英雄片。
英雄片是。
强南一的一种极限操作。
他是最强的男移了。
所以他在建立共情的时候啊。
是需要一些极限操作的。
他的。
供情相对弱。
需要进行极限操作。所以在英雄片里面啊，我们给英雄片。
写了这样一个。
就说英雄片的四个属性。
叫技能。
命门。
对手。
和使命。
英雄一般为什么叫英雄啊？一般来说他又没有一个很强烈的技能。
对吧？
这了这件事啊是很伤。
很伤共情的。
所以英雄片里面你。
这个缺陷设计我们叫坏习惯设计，缺陷设计。这个缺陷要大到什么程度？要大到是一个命门。
能要了他的命啊。
能要了他的命。
孙悟空的紧箍咒。
是不是那要了他命啊？
那个蜘蛛侠猛不猛，但是关键时刻他喷不出来。
能要他的命啊，就说。
你想要让他有多强的技能，就得让他有多强的命门，这样才能平衡到。
观众愿意跟你建立共情的程度。
而且你在拥有这个技能的时候，你必须拥有旗鼓相当的对手。
就你的对手也要很强，你不可能去打平民的。
你的对手也很强。
所以这个这个对手很强是什么意思呢？
是让你的环境险恶。
一定程度上造就了可怜。
也就是说你的可怜和你的可信呢。
全部做到极限了，你能明白这个意思吗？
正常人，我们只要做小可怜就可以了。在这里你的对手会非常凶悍。
然后呢，正常人我们做一个小缺陷，小坏习惯就可以了。在你做为英雄呢，你必须是个命门，是能要你的命的一个缺陷。
然后。
正常角色。
要做共情，我们只需要去救一只猫就可以了，救猫咪嘛。
你作为英雄。
你的拯救世界，明白这个意思吧？你你去看那种英雄片，动画片，没有是救猫咪的，他不他最后没有，他连救家人的都很少，救你的家人，就你心爱的女人都太少了，太小了。
都是拯救世界。
力挽狂澜，地球毁灭。
全是这种英雄片，他的使命就要达到这种程度。
所以你看英雄片技能，因为这个技能。
因为这个技能太强，让你脱离共情了吗？你需要三个东西去补这三个东西其实就是可怜可。
的极现操作。
明白这个意思吗？这就是极限操作。
我用一句话总结阴影片啊。
因为英雄片的技能让你脱离共情，所以一般的英雄片。
用一句话来总结，就是。
就是一个。
带着致命缺点的英雄。
对付一个几乎完美的对手。
往往是这样。
就是你的英雄啊。
他除了。
拯救世界这一点是正能量以外，其他的可以都是。
济公传。
济公。
济公除了干好事儿。
以外啊就惩个扬善，这确实是他的。
呃，牛逼的地方，其他一无是处。
对吧。
喝酒吃吃肉。
不洗头不洗脸，穿着破衣服，然后到处欺负人。
啊，不讲礼貌，不讲卫生。
就所以说是一个带着致命缺陷的。
英雄。
去对付一个几乎完美的对手，对手一般是流氓水花。
是道貌岸然。
呃，品学点优就是目的不好，目的不纯，老想统治世界什么的。你看所有的坏人全都是优秀生的。
品身俭油的。
所以说英雄别你记住这个口诀，一般来说都是。
一个致命缺陷。
带着满身缺陷的英雄。
对付一个几乎完美的。
坏蛋几乎完美的坏蛋就是这么矛盾，有点像什么啊？有点像我们人设里面经常说的牙刷跟大肠的理论。
什么叫牙茬跟大肠的理论啊？说你看啊。
呃，大肠你爱不爱吃，爱吃？
他是那大肠。
大肠的一辈子都是在装屎。
然后你为什么吃一个装着屎装屎的大肠呢？你说他们洗过了呀。
洗过就很干净了，他装了一辈子屎，但他最后洗过了，我觉得很好吃。
我们说那一个马一个牙刷，如果掉进马桶里，你还用吗？没有人会再用。
然后我说牙刷是很干净的东西，它一辈子都很干净，掉进了一次马头。
你就觉得他脏了。
你说这是什么原理？
这其实就有点像英雄。
和坏蛋。
你一辈子都是你几乎完美没有用。
就第一次马桶，你是只坏蛋。
你就是坏蛋。
大肠就是英雄，你知道吧？
因这。
从头到尾都是装屎的，但洗干净了，你就爱吃。
所以说我们。
对。
设计英雄片的时候。
呃，记住它是共情的极限操作，就是你可以让他浑身是屎。
但是呢。
目的。
呃呃，就是使命高尚。
那是个使命高尚，那他就是。
浑身是屎也不要。
而且浑身是屎是好事儿。
让你这里共情，你如果你设计一个啊道貌岸然。
呃，完美优等生。
的英雄，那这还看什么呀？
然后这个坏蛋是十恶不赦，浑身是屎。
那也就没得看了。
记住这个。
呃，共情的极限操作是英雄片。
写到的时候呃，记住一点。
这是题外话，关键是要掌握主角的共情。
好吧。
主角就说到这儿。